all right let's do this what uh what
topics you got today I've got a billion
of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
a billion dollars
all right so I'm gonna tell you some
facts about this Billy of the week and I
want you to see if you can guess who
this person is all right okay I'm game
so Steve Jobs so one time Steve Jobs
approached him uh on advice about
designing the Apple Stores and when they
discuss each of their products Steve
said to this guy I'm not sure if the
iPhone is going to be very popular in 20
years but I'm certain that your products
are definitely going to be popular so
that's one interesting thing about them
intriguing okay he's had multiple tennis
matches with with Roger Federer he lives
in a 150 year old castle
and last year his company did 84 billion
in revenue and 22 billion in operating
profits and this is my give it away this
year his company was the fourth largest
company in the world and oftentimes he's
number one on the richest person in the
world
the Louis Vuitton guy the Louis Vuitton
guy
[Music]
foreign
I don't know how to say his name because
it's French we're gonna call him Bernie
but uh it's uh it's Bernard Arnold I
don't know if the t's silent
sorry but it's it's usually not a hard
tea but we're gonna go with that
yeah is that a hard tea is that a soft
tea I don't know Bernie Arnie you are
the man so Steve Jobs really went to
this guy huh dude yeah and a lot of
people really respect this guy so I'll
like give you a little bit about his
background but some facts about him so
he owns 46 so the Louis Vuitton Empire
it's called lvmh so it's a multinational
luxury goods conglomerate deal market
cap of 430 billion oftentimes him Elon
and like Bezos go back and forth uh but
he's kind of the odd man out because
he's not like he like dresses really
nice and he like looks as like a someone
who owns Louis Vuitton would look he
like has this black turtleneck and a
nice sports jacket but he's been called
the um uh well I believe it's like the
the uh the wolf and cashmere sweaters or
something like that because he's like
he's pretty ruthless but he like dresses
nice but uh uh yeah I'll tell you a
little bit about them so at 21 it's kind
of an interesting fact I call you the
denim Fox right the denim box yeah yeah
I wish the Juggernaut
the dog and the Canadian tux that's what
I'm known for uh the denim dog uh so
listen at 21 Bernie joined his father's
Construction Company after finishing his
engineering degree and by 25 he was the
CEO of the company the company wasn't
small at all uh at the time it was doing
uh something like 10 million in Revenue
which is the equivalent to 40 million
now and had a thousand employees but
right when he joined he like he said
let's expand so we got into like some he
started investing investing the profits
and some Finance businesses into real
estate things like that then in 1981 he
goes to the U.S and he starts expanding
the business and eventually he like
specializes and specializes in town
homes sells a bunch of them makes the
equivalent of 75 million dollars now uh
which was 25 million back then or that's
what he sold his company for I don't
know what he made from it but there's an
interesting thing that happens so he's
in the cab he's in a taxi in New York
and he asked the taxi driver if he heard
of the president of France and the taxi
driver was like nope never but I know
all about Christian Dior who uh you know
Dior is like a like a luxury a luxury
brand and he started thinking he's like
Okay so this guy who's like just a
normal guy in New York doesn't know who
the president of France is but he knows
all about Christian Dior like maybe I
should explore uh like luxury Brands and
so he he buys the holding company
eventually of Dior and it was like all
like he got inspired by that first
taxicab meeting he raises a bunch of
money buys it fires a ton of people
turns it around sells like the other
brands Dr owns and it's a really good
success and that's like his first big
entry into luxury Brands then
in 1987 he gets the idea uh uh to buy
Louis Vuitton and he does the same thing
where he raises a bunch of money and he
buys it and he fires a bunch of people
and definitely turns on a big deal was
it doing was it very successful at the
time or was it like distressed it was
Christian Dior was like distressed when
he bought it they both were distressed
but they were both Brands and so that
kind of brings us to like the big Point
here which is do you I mean Louis
Vuitton has been around for hundreds of
years
um or at least 100 years um I think from
since the 1800s but they they were kind
of mismanaged so have you seen that
movie with I think it's Lady Gaga Lady
Gaga where she like is that how they say
it Lady Gaga
have you seen that movie where she plays
like the wife of like the Gucci guy and
like murders him I saw part of it yeah
yeah you saw the trailer to be honest
with you yeah it was only these but uh
you know big guy fan so uh they uh it's
like mismanaged so like a lot of these
family businesses they like have great
Style by it's kind of like you know like
a a singer managing their own career
like maybe like you know the left part
of the brain doesn't actually work well
with business but it works and stuff and
so it was the same thing where it was
definitely mismanaged he raises all this
money and he just turns him into an
operation Powerhouse and then he just
starts going on a on a spree where he
starts buying all this stuff so he owns
all these Brands he owns uh you know I
don't freaking buy any of this [__] so
I'm gonna look like an idiot talking
about it but Sephora which is like the
big makeup thing
um fenny which is another popular thing
Bulgari
Marc Jacobs like if everything that a
woman aspires to own he owns like a huge
portion of of that market but I want to
tell you about a few of the things
um that interest or that make me
interested in this guy and first have
you have you heard about him do you know
anything about him uh I had only seen
him because he's at the top of the rich
list and he's you know lvmh but I didn't
know I didn't know this backstory so go
on so what interests me about him is I
think Peter Thiel has this book what's
that book called that zero to one zero
to one and it's awesome
um I I really like reading that book and
it kind of had an impact on me where he
talked about like extreme personalities
and having extreme results and all about
like an engineering culture yada yada
yada but there's one part of the book
where he lists out all the moats he's
like you can have like you can like know
like a secret that no one else knows you
could have like a patent you could have
technology that no one else has whatever
but and then he mentions there's this
one moat called bran that's a huge moat
and I think he's like I never understood
brand so I don't know there's one sense
and he says this is definitely a boat
not for me I don't get it I don't
understand it and I always thought that
was funny because when a lot of like
tech people discuss moats they talk
about like technology Network's effects
rarely do they discuss brand well this
guy Bernie that's truly what he
understood where he was like no they're
like that's where all my margin is is
because I can create a brand I'm going
to create luxury goods I'm going to get
luxury margins and not only that it's
gonna live for forever so uh Louis
Vuitton by the way was founded in 1854.
and he his whole thing was like uh in 10
years there will be far fewer luxury
Brands and the ones that survive will be
more important because people are
getting richer and richer and richer and
if a brand has been around for 50 years
he thinks it can be around for another
50 or 150 years so that's like a soul
shtick and uh I thought that was
interesting and he um has this rare
combo of operational excellence and also
like good style and understanding brand
because typically
this might be an overreaching statement
but a lot of times these really rich
people are like maybe like uh what's his
name um uh Warren Buffett might be a
little bit like that where he like sees
like what a good business is and he's
like well I don't care this could
probably last for a long time let's just
do it I can look at the spreadsheets and
I can understand it and then other times
there's people who are like this is a
sick brand and they just totally but
they totally mismanage it and they're
not numbers oriented
but then you got a guy like this guy who
like does a pretty good job of like
being pretty ruthless that you like you
need to be in order to make the business
hugely profitable and very successful
but also like understands like vision
and some of these intangible things
basically like how to make [__] cool
which is very very very challenging it's
hard to have just that let alone both of
those features so I thought that guy was
interesting
um and he has a few interesting quotes
and I'll wrap up so luxury goods are the
only area which is possible to make
luxury margins for me luxury is how do
you create desire and then he says I'm
optimistic long-term pessimistic short
term so interesting interesting guy he
is here's another one I think that's
like um something about being rich
without
uh being famous he has some some quote
like that and he's not quite a recluse
but he like
owns this island in the Bahamas where he
spends most of his time obviously flies
private and is somewhat under the radar
compared to Bezos who's in the news with
his you know new girlfriend and things
like that this guy's pretty low-key and
his business he owns like all the voting
shares and all that and he when he dies
he always says he's giving 20 to each of
his five children and it's run like a
family business so in that regard he's
pretty low-key and out of out of the out
of media uh mostly right
uh yeah okay I can't really fully find
it but uh he had said some there's some
French phrase which is like the only
uh something about uh something about
being you know being happy uh
you know basically it was it was
something around the idea of you want to
be wealthy but not rich and he had some
cool French way of saying it but I can't
find it off top of my head here
be a lot cooler if you did but that's
all right
sure would
well that's my that's my Billy of the
week
dude I have another like weird internet
culture thing that I was uh kind of
related to like your engineers I was
thinking about this and I think that
what I'm about to say is incredibly not
normal but I think for you it's normal
and it's incredibly normal for me and
it's probably normal for a bunch of our
friends
so I was thinking about this we got we I
have this new researcher that you're
trying to steal from me a little bit
um and it's
I met him through a friend of a friend
but it all started on Twitter and the
Twitter DMS and without talking to this
person like uh uh whether a phone or or
Zoom or whatever meeting in person we
just like text and we hire them and we
do a business exchange and like you put
a lot of trust in one another
and I've realized I've done this like 20
times where someone like my best
co-workers and best uh some of my best
friends in fact it just started like
through internet culture and we very
rarely exchange words and we've done
like some relatively big business
together where we're like exchanging
tens of thousands of dollars a month or
we've invested one in other companies or
whatever so I've done it with
a partner on my latest company uh Joe we
basically were Facebook friends
yeah maybe only like six times
um but like we knew each other for like
five years before we really uh like
talked a lot in person I've done it with
this guy Diego who I'm helping him with
his agency business I heard a funny
story from about you on this so uh
somebody who's work with you goes yeah
Sam gave me the login to his Instagram
or something like that or to LinkedIn I
don't know what it was and what is it
that you requested back from this
internet stranger Sam
I asked for his social security number I
asked for his girlfriend's social
security number I asked for uh a picture
ID of both him and his girlfriend and a
utility bill so I knew exactly where he
lived
the sapphire School of background checks
like dude what is your plan okay let's
say what is he gonna do all right let's
say you post something or changes the
password what are you gonna do with this
utility bill and his social security
number what is your what is your your
revenge
well I don't know but I know it's scary
enough that if someone has that I don't
know sign them up for a credit card I
would I would show up to his house for
sure
yeah I don't know but uh I don't know
maybe it's like scary enough that it
worked but have you done this have you
like done business with a bunch of it's
not Anonymous people because you
actually get to know them but Internet
it's like a weird internet totally
that's like very normal now at this
point which is strange it shouldn't it
almost feels like it shouldn't be normal
but it is I don't think it's normal for
most people
I mean it just seems natural you see I
feel like I know these people I see
their writing or I hear their podcasts
or they they email me a bunch of times
and we go back and forth and then
they're in my slack and then sure enough
it's like hey
you know here's everything yeah here's
the keys to the castle and once you get
that once you're working together or
you're doing things together that builds
even more trust and it just layers on
and then you beat them four years later
and you're like you see them in person
and they're like nice to meet you
uh you know you don't know what to say
it's like nice to see your nice to see
your body
nice to see your face finally yeah like
sick legs dude I'm I'm okay not meeting
these people I I like it how it is if it
ain't broke don't fix it like I enjoy
these types of relationships yeah we
have this feature not a bug right for
sure and we have this one Dev I have
this Dev working on a project uh that I
have and he's in Hong Kong and he's in
high school
and he built this amazing thing and I
don't really know anything about him
other than I want to work with you for a
very long time and like I was just he
sent me some of his work and it was so
awesome and I just realized this is
super odd and also amazing and I don't
think a lot of people realize that you
could like do business like this because
I'll tell my family and they'll think
I'm crazy but it's become so normal at
this point that I don't even I forget
that it's not normal amongst others
right
right yeah totally I've also a lot of my
real life friends I just sort of like
shifted more to online I'm like hey
let's we can hang out 10 times more
through the group chat and through a
bunch of a bunch of these little like
like you know apps or things like that I
feel like I get to know them better that
way almost and you know anybody got time
to hang on in person anymore and now we
know why the birth rate in America is
declining rapidly but yeah this
basically like is uh a thing that I do
and I thought I should bring that up
because I don't think most people
realize like how some of that stuff
happens and it's actually quite random
how it happens but if I see like a 19
year old who's like impressive or like a
21 who's impressive and like writes well
and is like clever in my DMs some this
sounds like creepy but I'm like I'm I'm
I'm interested in giving them a shot on
something and so it's really cool how
these like little projects actually turn
into like pretty meaningful things after
a while right yeah they're iyb's
interesting young boys
[Laughter]
yeah pretty little things
rip no disrespect
all right I want to tell you about
somebody interesting I met recently too
so
did we talk about Chris uh Sparling on
the podcast yet
yeah so uh we have this great friend
named Andrew Wilkinson who has maybe
close to a billion dollar Empire and
Chris is his partner in crime and I had
never met him until we went to that
event in Vancouver for the show
and you guys are really similar you guys
are very similar me and him you have
similar some some similar uh parts of
you yeah yeah for sure
um a couple of a couple of observations
I would say about him
um I want you to tell him if you because
you've interacted with him right you've
met him
only a couple times but yeah and we're
both very interested in these kind of
like high performers especially in this
case it's a high performer who went and
built their own Island and did they won
in their signature way I think that
that's particularly what's interesting
to us like if somebody's just like
I don't know some VP at Google I'm a lot
less interested than somebody like Chris
who basically made their own path I
think he you know Andrew met him when he
was working at a bank he was like a
banker uh not like a cool investment
banker but like a go to the bank I need
to write a check banker and they started
talking about cars because Andrea drove
up in a cool car and uh they both nerd
out about cars and then they were like
okay what's going on you know what do
you need for you're getting like a line
of credit or whatever for your business
what's your business uh Chris was like
yeah I'm like studying to be like a CPA
or like I'm about to get my my license
to be an accountant or something like
that and um
Andrew was like hey you want to just
leave here with me and like you know
work with me
you know Chris it actually happened at
the bank he didn't say it like that but
he you know he offered him a job he said
you should come work with me uh like I
need help at the time Andrew just had
meta lab his design agency was doing
well and um had gotten to maybe a couple
million dollars a year of profit
um you know let's call it I don't know
four or five years in something like
that uh but so so he hadn't started what
became tiny which was acquiring a bunch
of other internet companies and so Chris
tells the story here's some of the
things that I took away from this uh
this this meeting so one interesting
part of the story he goes so my first
day at work I show up
uh Andrew's not there I'm just like
waiting at the door and
um 30 minutes go by Andrew's not there
Andrew rolls up in an Uber with like you
know one airpod hanging out of zero
whatever and he's got he opens up the
trunk he takes up this giant box full of
papers and he's like he's like you're
here okay fantastic here's uh all of our
papers for like you know here's the
business finances
um I gotta go to a meeting and there's
no office space for you so I talked to
my neighbor they have room in their
basement so just go knock on the door
tell them you're with Andrew and like
there's a desk in their basement and
like here's this box of papers then he's
like and I left and the Chris was like
man I made a huge mistake uh who is this
guy what is happening here he goes he
knocks on the door he's like hey um do
you have like a basement desk for me
yeah yeah come on in and it's like when
you see the guy with the hole in his
boot you know you're there make it right
all his food exactly he's like so that's
how it started and then I go okay so
then that time is just doing metal lab
so what how did this become tiny and he
goes uh
well we looked at the business and the
business was good business was
generating Revenue was generating profit
it's like okay well like what do we do
with this profit
um what are we supposed to you know
should we reinvest this in some way into
the business like could we grow can we
should we hire people he goes I don't
know what do all agencies do he goes
agencies hire a bunch of people uh and
then buy fancy offices and they put a
basketball hoop in the office like you
know they put a play pit in the office
and he's like
yeah that doesn't seem like a good idea
we should not do that that's kind of the
only thing they agreed on let's not do
that they go well
okay we can't follow agencies to figure
out what we should do like you know how
should we think about this and they go
well
look we're a business that has clients
and we have you know like uh service
team and then we have some profits like
we are a boring Law Firm Let's Just
Pretend We're a boring law firm uh let's
not try to be a cool agency let's be a
boring law firm and not get too high on
our own Supply okay so what what could
we do with these profits if we weren't
going to like try to just get flashier
and flashier with the design agency
um and that's where they decided let's
buy a Better Business than our current
business so like let's buy a business
that has recurring revenues maybe that
has less service oriented more of a
product and let's use the profits from
the service business to buy increasingly
better businesses so I thought I liked
that story that frame I enjoyed that and
what was the first thing that they
bought was it dribble
no that wasn't the first thing I don't
know I don't know exactly what the first
thing the bot is but honestly it was
probably another agency is my guess but
you know regardless now that's kind of
the start of their Journey
so I never met Chris Andrew uh talks a
little bit about him but you know you
never really know uh what people are
like here's my observations
Chris had the juice and it was very
surprising to me that Chris had the
juice because normally in these
Partnerships there's like the outgoing
uh face of the brand that everybody
knows and then there's like the quiet
silent but deadly operational partner
Finance partner or whoever partner
that's like doesn't really care about
the spotlight
um and usually is more reserved I would
say most of that is true but at this
dinner
I thought it was remarkable that he was
kind of like this like
it was shy but he still had the juice
and I've never really seen that combo
before like I think he would have rather
just been at home reading a book
but he had this thing which is like I'm
at this dinner so the flip is the switch
is flipped and he was like super
talkative and not not because he's Mr
Charisma or he's not like dripping with
like you know he's like this charm he
has wisdom it feels like he was he was
just like I would call it honest he was
just like he would ask a question and if
you said something he'd be like hold on
hold on so is it like this or he'd be
like but you're saying this is that
because you think that or is that
because your parents taught you that why
did you say that and he would say that
pointed that's what reminds that's one
of the ways in which you guys are
similar is you ask those same questions
I do and I so I was eating it up I was
loving it I was like oh this guy's right
up my alley the other thing he did those
like me but times ten is he was like Mr
framework exactly you guys are the exact
same way for that reason I called him
out in the dinner I was like bro you
have just named 14 different like
cognitive biases and one dinner it's
crazy like he'd be like it's like the
strike sand effect mixed with with the
thing that you know the the the the like
you know the sucker's bias and it's like
what are you talking about you yeah just
like an index he had an index of mental
models I was like this I was like did
you download Twitter threads and you
just memorized them like how do you know
all this and why are they so top of mind
for you and that's really how he thinks
he he truly seems to think that way
which I thought was really interesting
well you know why so Andrew told me this
I don't know like the what Chris's story
is but Andrew said they basically were
like building their own companies and
like reinvesting the profits into
building their own things and then they
read the biography of Warren Buffett I
think it's called snowball or something
and then they read like a Charlie Munger
book and they go oh yeah let's do this
instead and so they start buying
companies that work and they have the
you know like I think Tiny's website
says we buy wonderful companies that's
basically I think exactly what Buffett
said uh tiny is just we buy wonderful
internet companies and then yeah but
Berkshire just doesn't have internet in
it right and so they basically stole uh
you know a lot of Buffett's really great
ideas and also have you ever read a
Charlie Munger book or anything by
Charlie Munger yeah yeah for sure dude
their Frameworks about everything
there's like ones called like poor
Charlie's Almanac I think it's called
and it's like 88 different Frameworks I
started reading it and I'm like dude I
need a story here but yeah it was a very
strange book people say they love that
book and I'm convinced that anybody who
says they love that book hasn't actually
opened it because when you open it it's
not even like a book it's like a uh have
you seen have you have you actually
opened the book yeah I read the whole
thing and I found it very hard to even
remember it's hard to read dude it's
like it's like a list of rules yeah yeah
it's like the table of contents except
it's long it's a very challenging book
to read but I what I remember from the
book and then hanging out with Chris is
like oh you read a lot of Monger because
you guys are sort of similar in that
framework and another thing Buffett does
is like he'll say things I forget
exactly what he phrases but he's like uh
you know why kill a mice why kill a
mouse well we can go and shoot an
elephant like he'll say things like this
or he'll like create some analogy you're
picking up pennies in front of a
steamroller or yeah
we're talking about something he goes so
is that like diamically sword that slays
the Beast and I was like I was like what
the [__] are you talking about like I
was like uh I don't know what that is
what are you saying in English and he's
like no like you know the story of Daya
whoever there's some Greek guy and I was
like no I don't know any of these things
what are you talking about yeah it's
like dude I need an analogy for your
analogy but I've noticed that Chris uh
the Liberty the time that I've been
around him he does the same thing where
I can tell who he's read and he's really
good at what he does and I think he's
also naturally like that he just like
thinks in Frameworks and analogies and
things like that he can take complicated
things and make him quite simple totally
and he uh I think he's really really
like super curious which I really
respected about him like I felt like
when he was asking questions he wasn't
doing it to make conversation he was
doing it because he actually really
wanted to know the answer he was
genuinely interested and I think that
comes up comes off and I think that is a
huge um
like Saving Grace for I think people
overthink how to be in social situations
and like you know the easiest hack is
just simply genuinely be interested in
the other person everything else will
work itself out
um that's how I felt about Chris and I
really like that we had a interesting
different conversation I'll share one uh
one little tidbit that that can take a
dinner conversation from surface level
to a lot more interesting and um I
forgot who was talking it was the CEO of
something and
um she said something and I go
I go let me ask you a question a little
bit a little bit of a weird question can
I ask you and she's like yeah and I go
um growing up
I said what you said was really
interesting just now and it made me
wonder why you why you wanted that so
bad growing up whose love did you want
more your mom or your dad's oh my God
and uh you know she immediately like
started to take it take it back by the
question but then kind of answers and
then and people open up about their like
they open up about their relationship
with their parents and also like it's
kind of like where'd that chip on your
shoulder come from is really what this
question is asking and I stole this from
Tony Robbins Tony robbers asked this
question and I saw that like in most of
who he does he's like uh live kind of
coaching sessions or whatever with
people during his events and he had
asked this question and it immediately
found like the actual answer to the to
the problem and since then I've like
kept this question in my back pocket and
I asked it from time to time it's a very
revealing question
um hard to say without sounding like
just like a pretentious prick um yeah
did you have like your like glasses like
in your mouth like yeah yeah exactly the
tip of the frame
needs to go into the mouth and you have
to be wearing a turtleneck but if you do
happen to have a turtleneck on it is
such a good turtleneck question
that's ridiculous and it worked oh it
worked and then the whole the whole
table kind of shared their answers to it
and it went from like all right we can
either sit here and we'll go one inch
deep or like we ended up 50 feet deep
and I felt like everybody actually felt
like they knew each other and um and it
was like after the fact it was like so
what do you do again it's like you know
you're trying to it kind of reversed the
order of how most of these like kind of
networking dinners go and I've been to a
lot of these and so like I appreciate
something that can break out of that
that surface level you know surface
level stuff fluff that's not really that
interesting dude I was at this one
dinner recently and this guy who was a
younger guy and he was like a fan of our
stuff so he was and he like clearly like
was learning how to interact with people
like he was like an internet guy who
like read How to Win Friends and
Influence People and the first thing
that he said to me and my wife was like
he was trying to do what you did and he
asked us like when did you guys first
have sex and what was it like
I swear to God
and I like I I was so frustrated and I
was like I'll answer your question but
you got to answer mines first how much
money's in your checking account how
long is your dick and what was it like
when you saw your parents having sex for
the first time
and he was like what I go yeah that's
weird right I don't want to talk about
that don't be weird and he clearly had
like read like a book on how to do this
and then he like saw something you said
and I thought that would have been a
good idea and it wasn't it was a total
mess well there's something that you got
to do right you can't just ask out of
the blue oh he did the only reason this
question worked on ours was because when
somebody's explaining the chip like they
have this chip on the shoulder you're
basically it's a natural question to ask
where did it come from and then they
give you some [__] answer you say
all right let me ask you a different
question and you dig in that way you
can't just go up to somebody be like
hello I'm Sean nice to meet you hey I
was curious what's your deepest darkest
secret right like it doesn't really work
like that yeah it was weird man it was
weird it was one of these guys I'm uh it
was horrible uh but you pulled it off
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
all right what else you got
um okay oh I'll give you one other uh
Chris little gem that that came out of
the talk
uh somebody was telling a story about
somebody else and
and it was kind of a story that was like
uh what do they call it like a romp it's
basically like it's a rock like a like
it's like a it's like a tale about like
you're you know you could tell a tale of
like your drunken days and this the the
crazy thing that happened that we almost
got arrested then we ended up it's like
it's a story that doesn't have a lot of
like it's not like a meaningful story
it's an entertaining story and um
and so the person's telling the story
about like this business romp so
somebody was like gonna get rich and
then they like it went almost broke and
then now they're okay and like you know
whatever happened
and he goes and then the takeaway was
you know that you know that person they
said yeah they could have they could
have sold the top and made a bunch of
money but they said you know well if I
had done that then I wouldn't have blah
blah blah blah and he said something
that has stuck with me which he goes
do you think that's the right lesson to
learn out of that
and he got
he goes I wonder that sometimes he goes
people always talk about like how the
lessons Chris and he goes um
he was a question I often asked is like
is that is this person somebody who's
learning the right lesson out of things
and I thought it was so funny uh it was
like a blunt thing to say and so I loved
it already the second thing was it's so
true I look around the people around me
in life that I encounter
and very rarely like if like a lot of
people have experienced go through
experiences and think they learn a
lesson but if I was to measure like the
hit rate of are they actually having the
correct takeaway out of a situation
it's shockingly low and I think that
that is one of the greatest indicators
of success is are you actually able to
learn the correct lesson from your life
experiences
um nobody's 100 on that because we all
have weird things where we'll blame
other people or we'll glorify ourselves
and not realize that we just got lucky
we'll do weird things like that but um I
realize oh I want to only be around and
work with people and hire people who are
high on this score I don't really care
how much experience you have but if you
don't take away the right lesson from
the experiences you're going that you
have and that you're going to have your
rate of learning is just gonna like it
it'll be a different rate or you'll just
end up in some weird trajectory where
you'll just do dumb [__] because you're
taking away the wrong lessons from your
life experiences and I've I just never
heard somebody say that out loud and it
really stood out to me and it's like now
I see it everywhere that's a that's a
really good question I wonder if that is
something that he came up with or like
was inspired by I mean it's a hard thing
that's a really unique that's a really
unique I said it kind of as an offhand
comment this one wasn't one of his like
Frameworks or like go-to's I could tell
it was just like he literally just asked
the question because he was because it
was so he hurt like it was kind of like
uh you know when somebody starts a
sentence and you kind of your brain is
trying to fill in the blank of the last
thing they're gonna say and then they
say something's totally different you're
like that is not where I thought you
were going with that that's what
happened in the story it's like 90 of It
kind of made sense and then the last 10
at the conclusion was like some other
weird conclusion and he was like what
is that the way that was the conclusion
I feel like the collusion should have
been X but you're saying their takeaway
was why what uh and and so I don't even
think he really meant it that way or he
really put that much weight into it but
that was my my Golden Nugget of that
dinner was that one question and uh and
I can't I literally can't stop seeing it
everywhere now like my kid does
something my wife does something I do
something and I I started to think back
I was like in what areas did I take away
the wrong lesson like I don't know if
you think back in your life can you
think of an example where if you're
honest with yourself it's like yeah
actually I kind of learned the wrong I
kind of did I even learn the right
lesson from that was that the right
answer there's a few things like you
know how that phrase like fail fast
like I used to believe that that was
cool and then I'm like I'd rather
succeed fast like so yeah like I'd
rather not fail at like how could I
succeed faster than I fail and I
remember thinking it like for years I
was thinking well it's okay I tried
something and I'm like but like if I'm a
baseball player and I take lots of
swings but I don't get any hits like
that's bad that's not good that's very
bad so the lesson here is I should swing
and also have a high batting average and
I remember thinking like oh just shots
on goal that's all that's all that
matters but I'm like no I need a score
too and so for years like I thought it
was okay to fail because I'm failing
fast I'm moving fast I'm breaking things
whatever and then I'm like
maybe I shouldn't break things and I
should actually like succeed fast and I
remember like that like it changed like
five years ago
yeah yeah totally uh yeah I can think of
a bunch of examples in my life where
I've I think messed that up but now
that's not the case did you learn the
right lesson when you got roasted by
some people for posting your private
Chef dude you posted this picture of
this nice looking food and people are
like dude your blood glucose is gonna
Spike and you're gonna be so
unproductive because you're eating rice
uh I thought that was pretty funny all
the oh
yeah also that wasn't rice
whatever it was people were like giving
you a hard time I thought it was pretty
funny you only caught three a few of
them there's three four reactions
reaction one so what did I do I posted a
tweet that was just like
a delicious meal I was so happy I was
having this meal I said best life
decision was hiring hiring a family chef
and um
there was four reactions there was the
uh predictable positive which was oh yum
looks good
predictable negative which was
uh hey douchebag people are struggling
in the world you're posting this like a
nice Flex you know [__] uh so there's
predictable negative
there was the predictable
um next question which was how much does
this actually cost
um you know like what goes into this
which is a fine question no problem and
then uh and then there was just like you
know whatever the sort of like the the
random or like the the interesting I
think the person who had the right
answer from it which was
you either should just move on if it's
not interesting to you or if it is
interesting to you you should be like
yeah that's something I want in my life
let me put bring that back to the front
of my brain
um as something that like you know I
kind of want and um
I thought that I thought it was very
funny I didn't even know I wanted that
until
I met somebody who had a private chef
and I was like wow this is incredible so
you're telling me like instead of them
having to cook three meals a day and
they're you know also they have a wife
and kids like you know instead of their
whole family have to cook three meals a
day do grocery shopping do the dishes to
end up with a meal that doesn't taste as
good isn't as healthy
um and takes up you know probably on
average three to five hours you know per
day if you average it all out including
the the groceries and the cleaning and
the cooking and the all of it
um
and you know but by the way three hours
a day out of your like you know people
have only have like 16 waking hours
right like this is a it's a really
significant chunk of time per day I was
like well I saw it I was like oh that's
a goal that I didn't even know I should
have but I want that and I want that way
more than I want uh uh you know a ski
home in Tahoe or like a fancy car or
those types of things and then I for I
didn't do anything about it for a while
because I assumed oh you got to be like
a billionaire to have that no you can
get them for as cheap as maybe a
thousand a month maybe and then I was
like oh let me do the math like how much
do you actually need to do this and then
I did the math I was like oh I think I
could do this now and then I just did it
and my life got way better and so I
posted it because hey just whatever it's
Twitter I didn't really think too much
about it but like
um you know there is a benefit in seeing
somebody's uh like somebody do a
decision in Life or have something in
life that is attractive to you and
brings it you know to your attention and
makes you think about do I want this do
I not uh can I have this can I not you
know I think there's some value in that
too so anyways that's that's my story on
the tweet I thought it was pretty funny
um I thought it was hilarious I am I was
frustrated you didn't like holler at
some of these people I almost started
replying to them for you yeah I haven't
decided if I'm a heel or a face yet so
to use wrestling terms like
um I'm tempted to just be a heel uh you
know like it's way easier in the today's
world I would say like uh what's his
name the the dude who loves Keith for
boy yeah I call them out I I don't like
that guy well you don't like him because
he's a heel right
uh you know he basically
um doesn't mind pissing people off
telling people telling people off
whatever it is and like that's his brand
and he and some people are like man I
love it this guy just tells it like it
is or he's funny or you know he must be
you know he he basically has his Aura of
I'm better than you like like many great
wrestling villains and um and he'll tell
you how much you suck and so people some
people hate that a lot of the majority
of people hate that and then there's a
minority people that love that and find
him like interesting and either way you
can't ignore him he's like you have to
take a position because it's so
um polarizing it's not just like you
know vanilla and I would say you
actually do a lot of what he does where
uh I don't think you think you're doing
it uh because you're like I didn't say
anything bad it's like bro you put a
period at the end of that line that just
you're saying like
a finger you know that's not a period
um do you know you're doing it when
you're doing it or not all the time
maybe some of the time but I think I
don't like um
like I'm kind of a stickler with
language like I like using certain words
so if someone like
says something and they end it in a
question mark my reply will be like I
don't know if you're asking a question
or if you're getting me to agree with
you you're stupid or yeah
what I mean like I just it like I just
like or when people like sensationalize
things like we'll just say like well
this happens all the time like for
example someone replied to you and they
go I've been seeing a lot of this lately
my exam what I want to reply with is
like oh okay well what are some other
examples
what are you talking about I'm a
stickler with language I don't like when
people say this always happens or this
never happens or these people are
everywhere like things like that I don't
like that phraser this is so common uh
that it's becoming an issue I'm like
well I I actually don't think that it's
any more common than it has ever been uh
anyway so I'm an [__] about that um
you wanna do one more topic
yeah uh let's do uh do you have one no I
blew my load early oh wow
uh and the internet thing but I think it
is that I generate so many more ideas to
do let's go let's did your mommy not do
you or your daddy not love you if we
look at the three years that we've done
this I think it Ebbs and flows I think
that each person goes on a chance dude
dude each person goes on a three-month
like reader dude 100 I think you talk
more but I don't think that
I don't think that you necessarily bring
more topics right right uh I think that
but I'll let you believe that
thanks for your permission when I was
selling the hustle you carried me when
you were selling milk Road my shoulders
got tired that's all I'm gonna say
yeah
that's all I'm going to say so I think
it Ebbs and flows there was a there's a
guy who basically took every idea from
the podcast and put it in a database
this is how I know I win because he took
every idea from the podcast and took put
in a database and he said it was 75 be
25 you but that's specifically on ideas
not topics that's maybe ideas yeah yes
like this Bernie guy that's not an idea
right come on that's that that's that's
you're definitely you're definitely the
king of the building of the week I think
uh you somehow know a bunch of these old
ass [__] in different spaces
and uh and you you find these guys I
don't know how you find these guys or
how you think of just Wikipedia bro yeah
but like why do they even get on your
radar you'll be like this guy used to
own this coal mine and then he bought
the Shoe Factory and then he owns like
you know you ever read the St Louis Post
and I'm like nah you know he owns that
so I'm like I don't know how you found
but you know more power to you I just
[__] books can I give you okay let me
give you a couple uh let me do an idea
I'm gonna go rapid fire I'm gonna just
empty the chamber here on some some
things that have been on my list
um I have a d2c idea that I'd like to do
pass uh but I'd like to do I means I'm
not gonna do it but I want to invest and
advise somebody who does it who's really
good wait do you still ever want to
launch an Ecom store uh I don't know I'm
torn I don't want to operate it myself
but I do want to like incubate them I do
want to like incubate them and hire a
CEO that would run them in theory but uh
that might also be difficult
um
so I have a a gut health one so gut
health is uh this is nothing new so let
me just start this by saying oh bro this
that exists yeah I know it exists
um almost every DDC idea you've had
exists
um
gut health is a uh a trend that is going
up up and up and it fits a sales model
that really works with d2c what do I
mean by that
you mean you could just buy it over and
over again you never know if it actually
works so what works in d2c uh a d2c pro
a great d2c product is one that is going
to be high margin so maybe uh can you
get to 75 80 gross margins well with
supplements you can get to 80 85 percent
gross margin so that's fantastic on the
product itself the next thing that works
in d2c is that it's a repeat purchase or
it's a consumable so something that
somebody's going to buy many times
they'll shop from you again and again
because either they ran out they ate it
they drank it or the you know the
deodorant stick ran out whatever it is
unlike a mattress unlike a mattress
um so so you want something that people
grow out of or run out of and um
so so high purchase rate well
supplements have that as well health and
wellness has that
um as well you want something that is a
uh is a problem solution fit so
basically you want something that is not
just like a kind of nice to have fashion
item what works better uh in what sells
better is something that you can just
say
do you have this problem we have this
solution and this is why you see if you
go scroll down to the bottom of a New
York Post
article you're going to see a toe fungus
ad why is a toe fungus ad always there
because guess what people have toe
fungus it's a very easy problem to point
out and people are looking for a
solution and willing to buy something
that tells that that promises them that
it's going to go away so uh you probably
do remember
um the problem the best promise solution
ever is uh Claude Hopkins he invented
the advertising for toothpaste in the
1920s and he said rub your tongue over
the your teeth you feel that film now
brush with our toothpaste Crest now rub
your tongue over your front teeth
that was the best problem that's like an
easy to understand like oh I see exactly
what you mean well in this this solves
it why that one's even better is when
you get to be the one diagnosing the
problem you have way more Authority and
you're basically creating a new problem
category for people that they weren't
fully aware of and so this happened is
why I like gut health a lot five years
ago I didn't hear anybody talking about
gut microbiome leaky gut I personally
leaky gut I'm sure there was something I
love that phrase it's beautiful branding
I have a family member who's just like
oh I'm super worried about leaky gut and
I'm like what and she's like yeah I
bought every book I watch these YouTube
videos and dude it scares the [__] out
of me and like now I drink apple cider
vinegar I do this I do that I'm like hmm
interesting somebody just like created a
problem taught you about it you might or
may not have it no way to know it's a
beautiful bunch of solutions and it was
branded in this way that sounded
horrible I don't want a leaky gut it's a
it's a it's a speed it's a it's spooky
it's what it is it's a spooky phrase
just like cleansing it's like I'm gonna
do one of juice cleanse like bro I don't
think like this juice is like a pipe
cleaner and it like is going through
pipes I don't know if that's how it
works so I um so I bought this domain
drink guts.com and I have this idea of
this brand called guts and guts is
basically a drink that uh that you drink
for it's like it's like a protein powder
and you drink it for gut health and um
it helps with digestion so a lot of
people who are either constipated or
going to the bathroom all the time uh it
helps with weight loss it helps with
sugar control helps with those those
sorts of things
um so yeah so I think I can incubate
this brand and I just need an amazing
marketing CEO and so I'm looking for
that
um have you uh have you heard of Ollie
pop uh I've heard of Lollipop I've drank
an ollipop before yeah so ollipop is
basically it looks like a soda or a
Seltzer it looks exactly like this I'm
drinking spin spin Thrift right now it's
just like water with a little bit of
fruit in it it looks just like that
except it says like probiotic on the can
yes which always turns me off by the way
I'm like nah turns me on probiotic dude
no who's antibiotic you
dude I'm antibiotic I'm not probiotic
I'm neutral on the biotics at least but
I'm definitely not pro but uh you know
how do you feel about accidents
are you pro-oxidants
dude
Michael Scott said he goes I wouldn't
say I'm superstitious but I am a little
stitches uh
uh lollipop do you know how big they are
I think they're huge dude I see them at
every grocery store 100 million plus and
they're doing a new one by the way poopy
or poppy using this one no it's like an
even more uh it's like a gut health soda
or like a probiotic like Lacroix and I
see that one popping up at Whole Foods
dude when I think probiotics I think
diarrhea like you're gonna do something
to my poop like yeah I think that's
where the branding opportunities come in
uh to to fix that guts doesn't exactly
help your cause here I know but I think
it's a loud
um splashy name that can be almost like
so bad it's good and uh
I don't think it's very trademarkable I
think that's the the problem with it but
I kind of want to work with a designer
just to make a fake CDC like packaging
of this I kind of want to crowdsource
this idea through MFM so basically I'm
like let's find a marketing CEO through
this I have I have a guy in mind
um let's get somebody who's a design
agency like let's make the packaging for
fun and uh and see what we could do
somebody who's like a supply chain guy
let's go find the formulation lab like
let's just like crowdsource this idea I
think that would be like dude here's
something I want to test so this what
you're saying reminds me so we're in the
55th minute or something like that of
this pod and you're saying like
something where you want to you're
saying a call to action I'm curious how
many people you're gonna get
last episode or two episodes ago I we
were talking about my Airbnb and I said
marathonranch.com I go yeah if it's
Airbnb you can see that
marathonranch.com and I just kept
talking
uh I was curious how many people went to
the site
um do you have a guess
oh I mean I would guess it's low I'm
gonna give you the homie yes I don't
know 100 visits so we set it at minute
38 or something like that like not in
the beginning it got like three or four
thousand views and uh not one not one
booking by the way not one booking not
one to be clear yeah one time I shared
it on Twitter and I got two million
impressions not one booking so not one
booking so it didn't help me at all but
I'm curious I bet you you'll get maybe
15 qualified people messaging you one
time you talked about this thing you
wanted a woman to holler at you for this
woman brand that you were working on and
people started hollering at me to get to
you and like four of them were like
Instagram women like models like wearing
thong bikinis and [__] like trying to
reach me to to talk to you and my Sarah
was like I saw my phone I'm like dude
this lady like she's like what are you
looking at I'm like check this out this
lady just dm'd me try to talk to Sean it
was it was a pretty funny
yeah I also like that you say holler at
still uh it's like is that still saying
tight when I think something's cool I'm
a Dank I'm trying to bring dank back do
you remember dank
TRL when I get home from school so
um you can just email me Sean
seanpuri.com I'll put it in the show
notes of this like in the description of
the podcast too
um I heard an assistant that just
reads all my email and triages it into
buckets that's like uh action item needs
a reply read this and in case you're
interested and then
um she filters out a bunch of crap
I went from being horrible at email like
I I don't see stuff I should I see a
bunch of stuff that's trash I forget to
reply to things I'll read it on my phone
thinks to reply later never never
remember to come back and reply later I
had a horrible system and now
um shout out to my assistant Andrea
who's uh helping me so much with that
it's it's like literally overnight Game
Changer well I got an email from her
saying Sean would like to schedule time
to speak with you in Vancouver and at
first I was like what the [__] [__] are
you kidding me there's some current
videos yeah
really uh and then I was like
okay this is awesome and I message you I
go who where'd you get this person from
very interesting she did a good job so
um by the way your call to action thing
just reminded me I think we should do
two things uh uh two upcoming shows I'm
gonna put it out there now it's time for
another drunk ideas episode uh which is
where we come up with ideas that only
sound good if you're drunk so half-baked
kind of bad but maybe good startup ideas
so we should like the very long distance
girlfriend the best one ever yeah
exactly very long distance Girlfriend
Was An Old Timer
um the second one is uh I think we
should do our version of The Bachelor so
I think we should get mfm's most
eligible
uh guys and gals basically submit your
application we need a photo we need
we'll we'll put up we should put up like
a dating site which is basically like um
uh we ask a couple questions and then we
take the best and we present them on uh
on the show and then people can reach
out to them and they will get like a
bunch of inbound of people who want to
actually date them and let's see if we
can get somebody married out here let's
see if we can get somebody to fall in
love the second time we've done that by
the way we've had one MFM marriage but
did you um
divorce yes
and that's not a joke but then we take
it away
did you see when I did that on Twitter
where I like tweeted out like 10 of my
friends who were single and yeah that's
a great idea we should just do that as a
crush it crushed all right I'll uh tweet
that out after this uh let's do this by
the time this comes out let's make it
like Ben texted me he wants to do he
wants to call it hot millionaires in
your area
um
what can we call it so what should we
call it it could be uh maybe something
with singles maybe something with uh
uh let's see what else
I don't know we got to get you're a good
name right no no no don't give up you
could do this I don't know we could
change the word singles with shingles is
there anything there that's the thing
that's always at the bottom of the
website it's like hot singles in your
area so just call it that like it's hot
singles in your area too much
competition on that name dude that's
that's the most competitive term on the
Internet
it's got to be like uh
um MFM Most Wanted and but it's most
wanted because
you you know they're wanted in a dating
sense yeah we get it we get it mfm's
Most Wanted that's fine that's actually
great that's actually great we're gonna
do that and then better than shingles I
don't know I like I like changing words
you know called Twitter [__] uh
it's classic
and then this month Sean we probably
should do like a merch thing
yeah I'm working on it I'm going all in
on uh on uh just creating great content
I don't understand what content has to
do with merch uh it's like merch's
content to be like we're not gonna be a
rich selling T-shirts but we can make
awesome t-shirts that are like as good
as great content like it makes you laugh
it's interesting it's cool it's fun it's
you know it's it's meant for fun not
meant to be like uh
you know our patreon all right I'm down
no offense people on patreon
little [__]
yeah dude I don't want to be like I
don't have a patron
um all right that's the pod
[Music]
thank you